hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to sucker for love
sorry it's been a bit of a delay on this
i've been a little busy but now we have
the third date with a cat lady and
zombies and zombies and zombies i think
this might be a multi-headed monstrosity
but it couldn't be any worse than what
i've seen so far so
i'm assuming this is going to go only
well for me chapter 3
chapter 3
[Music]
thank you for saving me for myself i
would not have been able to pronounce
that properly fear of the unknown is the
single strongest fear of mankind
terrors from beyond the borders of
knowledge okay
nope
okay hello
and yet the truest
has been in mankind's cradle since the
beginning
and walks the earth amongst us now
great i'll be right back it's gonna be
sweltering hot in here and not just from
the passion
mostly from the passion
[Music]
anyway
for true evil exists not in the devil
unseen but the devil seen and
unrecognized
sure
when you meet her you realize that
tucking away the rest of the horrors to
the unseen corners of the stars
is a blessing
okay
a shade of a thousand manifestations
each more horrific than the last
cool
she serves only one whose chaotic and
phantasmagorical wishes she obeys with
extreme prejudice phantasmagorical
but enough about me let's talk about you
oh she big
oh you're talking to me right now oh you
big
oh you big lady
[Music]
i respect your power and i will hear
nothing of this from you i can tell
you've got thoughts forming inside your
nogs i will not have it
hey
okay let's talk about me
hi you're the one that lenetta calls
darling and that esther calls dearest
aren't you i don't exactly remember what
they called me but you can call me
whatever you like
dog i i
this dread it's like when i first met
lynetta but this time it's sustained
like a state of constantly being
breathless
oh i know what you mean
smash
the very air has become unfamiliar and
alien to me saturated with infinite
malevolence it is impossible to breathe
smash the veil has been pierced and the
outer cosmos has revealed its limitless
cruelty in the form of this avatar of
insidious implication
smash
its very presence as sails ass asshails
ass ass ales asshails my mind turning it
against itself and all that is decent
there at the terminal precipice i
learned
the terror not only haunts it speaks
smash speak up i'm an older god so i'm a
little hard of hearing
are you or are you not the human that
has been dating my nieces i wouldn't
exactly call it dating
but yes normally i'd have an ounce of
defiance in me and i'd demand that she
introduce herself first but now i feel
it in my very bones i'm being talked
down to by something far beyond me
talk down to me all you want lady i i am
good good would you like a cup of hot
tea
a cold glass of water both in one cup
please you're offering me something to
drink you've been through a lot i just
wanted to ensure you're at ease for now
i've never been easier in my life
nyan la fotep no i just meant it's odd
for you to be a guest in my room and
offer me something are you certain this
is your room
well
i'm gonna go with yes but then again i'm
not very sure the very floor beneath my
feet feels mercurial and unreliable
shifting nightmarishly in non-euclidean
vertigo
who are you who am i
i am the obscure the unutterable i am
the crying chaos
you must be uncomfortable i suspect that
you have some back pain for multiple
reasons
why don't you lay down mankind pushes
out into the unknown
i am the unknown that pushes back
but just like my troublesome nieces
you can just call me aunty nyanyan
i'm not gonna do that i'ma call you big
lady so big lady
how you doing
big neon energy i erk unlike with
lanetta or esther i can't overcome the
unnerving presence overwhelming my
senses i feel violently sick
never been visited by someone so high up
in rank as me have you
i am honored silly question there's only
one that outranks me and if you had met
her neither of us would still exist i
don't think i want to meet anyone else
ominous vistas of terror open from every
corner of my mind i want to run
shrieking and wailing and alas
i've nowhere to go
i don't want to go still holding on
i expected you to last long enough to
chat but it seems you're nearing your
limit you have no idea what my limit is
let me offer you some words of assurance
i'm the last outer god you'll ever have
to see great
what do you mean i mean that things are
about to return to abnormal oh good
that's great for me hang on i need to
hydrate
sorry i suddenly felt myself being
violently thirsty eldritch horrors will
return to being obscure boogie men that
stuck unbeknownst to their prey the veil
shall be lowered again until the gate
opens and mankind is eradicated i kind
of have this funny feeling the mankind
was eradicated you'll never see me or my
family ever again i guess this is our
last moment together
but why why do you want to split us up
you know that even amongst gods there
are things that are strictly taboo
no i did not know that you see whenever
mankind starts exploring too far too
quickly you accelerate the end of all
things hmm so it's like a climax of
sorts so we appear to slow things back
down
we scare you back to the safety of the
familiar hmm okay
well nothing about this is familiar and
it's not scaring me
evils and destructive mantras to the
most dangerous of your kind to ensure
progress slows
because the longer you stay afraid the
longer you live okay to put it simply
once mankind isn't afraid of us anymore
everything will come to an end hmm
come
humans are doomed to explore and once
mankind makes the last discovery
once mankind reaches the edge of the map
you'll fall off
what are you saying so if there's one
thing that is certain amidst this
infinite cosmos
it's that for all of time our
relationship is shepherd and livestock
as we set the pace to the slaughterhouse
in that context outer gods and humans
being romantically involved is beyond
taboo
[Music]
it's upsetting the natural order and is
a conflict of interest to say the least
hmm
now all of this i can forgive because my
troublesome nieces led you astray
i know you didn't mean to participate in
such a grave taboo
right
hmm i guess i didn't know but i totally
meant it then we can work together to
ensure it'll never happen again well
if everything's gonna go back to the
abnormal
what's one more you're familiar with
these books yes
i had one made for just this occasion
do what needs to be done
perform the banish moo ritual
banish
what will mu
do
moo is the bookmaker so it will prevent
eldritch gods and humans from dating
ever again okay well counterpoint how
about a smooch if i'm sure you've got
lips in there somewhere no more books
can be made and the entity responsible
for bridging the gap between our realms
will be destroyed
our relationship will return to strictly
business in a manner of speaking well if
it's already going to do that then you
know none of this really counts i i
don't want to do not force me to remind
you the grave seriousness of the
situation
i promise you've never seen anything
like what i can do
[Music]
you know i see this smooch bar up here
and i got a sneaking suspicion i had a
question first
how come you're so tall the other gods
i've met didn't have so much trouble
standing in my bedroom
i'm not always this tall sometimes i'm
shorter sometimes i'm taller i have over
a thousand forms
i need to do another can i see him
please
and this one is a two-story tall cat
girl in high heels 37 of my forms are
that checks out
okay cool well this is great and all uh
well i'm just gonna
take a shower
oh blue
hmm i'm gonna step outside don't mind me
pick it up wow that's not the city yeah
who needs a city i've got a two-story
tall a two-story like one and a half
story i think i don't know it's hard to
say
you got a hat
all right i'm so so sorry she forced me
to make this book she said she'd spare
me if i let you banish me instead to
destroy me draw this symbol and chant
bye i hope that love will be your black
fire in total darkness
[Music]
[Music]
okay black light in total darkness okay
so you say
so you say
all right
black light in total darkness i mean not
total darkness
oh
[Music]
oh
god oh oh god oh god okay
the lights go out and won't turn on your
curse by ten nebrosity horror
[Music]
hmm if you feel burning sensation in
your blood and your flesh begins to melt
your curse by the caustic humor's [ __ ]
put a mask and robe on as quickly as
possible to preserve your form with the
mask on wash your face and you will not
like what you see if you do not wear the
mask
wash until the burning abates oh good if
you hear something strange that is
getting louder with time it is not just
your imagination it can kill you go
outside if you can see the source of the
strange noise cast is counter evil
okay
good god never trust any written words
besides mine if writing has become to
appear anywhere on your home writing on
the wall is after you ensure that
there's no writing on your body check
your mirror off and wash any writing off
your face you wrote it without realizing
it do not touch your chalkboard chant
three times
oh god
if you hear suspicious voices calling
out to to you check your window if you
see something upsetting do not go
outside no matter what you hear do not
open your door for it
if you hear scratching glass check your
reflection if you see something strange
run away from the mirror immediately do
not make eye contact or trust me or in
any way retreat into your bedroom and
turn off all the lights reflections
can't exist where there is no light if
it gets in the room there is nothing you
can do
okay if you are unable to speak or
perform incantations you have been
silenced do not try to scream grab the
ritual knife and go to the bathroom with
a mirror use the mirror to cut out
foreign objects in your mouth
if you start to turn invisible while you
move you are being spirited away
they are looking for you they want to
take you away do not bother hiding
pretend to be alive by standing in a
room as well lit as possible and remain
perfectly still hold your breath do not
move so much as a finger while they pass
you through
routinely check that your doors are
still closed if there are a jar closing
you only have moments to do so if he
enters your home he won't leave without
taking something with him however if you
wear a mask and have a life form on your
person he may spare you and leave only
with the life form if you wake up
unharmed he has taken your deal this
will only protect you once
there's no telling what will happen if
she uses this hex against you if your
true form reveals itself outside your
home there's nothing we can do to stop
her i'm sorry we gave it our best shot i
hope the end comes swiftly
interesting okay this is a
this is a lot
this is a lot okay i'm gonna die many
times but hey
draw this symbol instead
while wearing your ritual in mule lit
okay well this is gonna be troublesome
ritual amulet
draw the cross symbol instead in the
circles
all right no time like present here we
go
looking for this dog well i kind of was
yeah you may be capable of pulling a
fast one on my nieces but nothing
escapes my gaze
i think you'll find it quite impossible
to cast that counter evil without this
amulet
now my stray sheep it's time i shepherd
you back in line okay but first
smooch
oh
you
trixie
come on what's a smooch come on
all right so
i need i need to be on the lookout oh
god i have no idea
oh
what is that
what was that i hear noises wasn't there
a noise thing
if i
hear strange noise oh oh there we go
okay go outside
let's go it's uh that's wait multiple
holes oh it's holes okay wait
oh goodness gracious
uh oh god
oh what was this one there was one where
to go uh oh here we go uh
wear a mask and stand in front of the
mirror
oh god that's not good
hang on
hold on
wash
until the holes were filled wasn't that
it take my deal dog
oh wait oh god this isn't good
that's not good i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die
that's oh
wait no i don't have
wait
if lights
okay the holes will multiply where the
mask is stamped from the mirror oh i
chant
it wasn't wash it was chant
something terrible has happened
the earth while man was still rocking in
its
[Music]
if you feel a burning sensation uh if
you hear something
i'm turning invisible
oh god uh don't bother hiding hold your
breath
well lit as possible okay lit
lit
and don't move
[Applause]
am i good
no i'm not good
don't move a finger
[Applause]
okay it's still there so i just need to
not move
an eye opener for you imperceptible race
appearance what does that mean
okay that one's done imperceptible race
i don't know
i'm
oh god okay
i ain't moving i did i closed it oh [ __ ]
i'm doomed
hold on
i meant to oh
i'm dead aren't i
[Applause]
okay
do you believe your mind is still on
your side maybe i don't know what do you
what do you mean do you still trust it
kinda we'll see who it sides with soon
it'll side with you i guarantee it
your voice won't be hurt again okay
voice won't be heard again okay
that one is uh
voice
silence something silent something yeah
uh go to a ritual knife okay ritual
knife okay a tool knife
for the bathroom mirror cut out what i
see cut cut cut cut cut cut
good
excellent
did i do it
maybe i need
okay
voices voices crying
uh
my lights
okay horses okay it must be the the
outside one
i see oh
that's weird
was that too easy for you
we've only begun to lift the veil okay
cool
lift the lift away thy veil let's see
how you handled the next one dog okay
sure
uh what was that
i don't what what what it what is what
what is that what is
uh
there is no escape
i don't know i i oh oh my god is it is
it oh god okay i don't know what that is
what do i do shadows shadows some shadow
thing
uh
is this this thing is
as it did you must believe this ritual
okay
it's i think it's this one
oh my god
[Music]
did i do it you expected those to be a
challenge how well you know that's how
it goes huh these next horrors won't be
so easy to dispel oh we'll see what they
seem to be doing pretty good job
outside your window
it's nothing it's nothing
okay it was something about yeah if you
get don't trust any written words
besides mine
uh ensure that no writing on your body
okay
no writing on my body
no writing on my body okay
do not touch your chalkboard
oh god watch that [ __ ] off
nope i don't care about that nonsense
you think i'll let you become a legend
huh
what
okay uh did i do it
there was something about a door right
is it still doing the writing on the
wall thing no there's no writing on the
wall anymore
what's going on in there
no
uh-uh okay there's got to be something
about i remember seeing something about
the window
check your window if you see something
upsetting don't open your door for it
okay that's upsetting
starting to have trouble
are these horrors becoming too
challenging for you no no no no no
oh you can't begin to imagine the
horrors i can show you now show me
anything and soon you won't have to
imagine okay i don't
i will anyway
[Music]
okay
oh oh it's the whole one okay
so
i'm becoming okay wear masks stand from
the mirror chant until the holes are
filled okay mask
stand from the mirror
chant until holes are filled
that's not good
wear the move mask
okay
dog yeah
i'm impressed oh
a little crack in your facade there eh a
little bit of via
markiplier
charm wearing on you you've got backbone
for a human of your age
yeah but i doubt your will to survive
will last much longer oh we'll see about
willpower
milady
big neon
okay what do you got for me what do you
got for me
i can do this i can do this
suffering is born uh does that mean i'm
is that the burning thing
oh
my
god what
okay
was that the whole deal thing ah i
forgot about that
maybe i should just uh keep let me keep
that suffering is born i don't know what
that means is it the mirror thing no
oh god
oh god oh god oh take take the turtle
is that it i don't look at it
it might just be i don't look at it
okay oh god damn it
that's probably it for me
i'm insane
i don't remember that one
did i get a checkpoint
ah so close okay
damn it
all right let me what i'll do is it'll
help because i can read through it
anyway
okay let's read through and really get
these under my belt and then i'll know
okay
so i've got the porous one that needs a
mask
um
insects is not a big deal the lights go
out and won't turn on okay that's the
darkness one is there only one symbol
that i need
on the board after this one i think it's
only one symbol so i should just keep it
on this one
but what was the thing that killed me
something about something getting in
right tormentor
scratching on the glass that's not what
i heard i mean it might have been this
actually ah right i probably should have
done this
okay let's just go ahead and prep
i need
this symbol
i'm gonna go ahead and wear the mask and
keep the ritual knife and have the
life form
the turtle because a lot of these i
don't think that any of them need you to
not have things
put the mask and robe on as quickly as
possible so
why not okay all right let's try this i
think i got it i think i got this okay
hey
we're gonna do a thing don't worry
looking for this
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay i'm gonna go ahead and put
this other symbol here okay and i'm
ready
okay flesh becomes porous it's this one
okay go to the bathroom
and repeat until the holes are filled
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah what's that outside your
window what is that okay so this is the
door one don't open any writing on the
wall this is it don't touch your
chalkboard
okay and i gotta check and wash my face
good
no no no no no no no no it's nothing
it's nothing
you think i'll let you become a legend
a legend
you think me legendary okay ah i don't
like what i saw out there therefore i
will
actually was right here yep
okay i have what i need i know what i
need to do that i need to cut out the
okay
and then that that thing the noise is
getting louder wasn't that the noise is
getting louder
i think it was
yeah that's it okay um
if you hear if you hear yup go outside
this
i expected those to be a chap
nope okay
all right what do you got what do you
got
oh i don't like the quietness
suffering is born what does that mean
i don't think i got this one right
before suffering
what does that mean
oh god oh my god okay
okay
[Music]
i feel like i'm playing five nights at
freddy's again
you [ __ ] oh you [ __ ]
[Music]
not today
not today
no stop it
am i supposed to chant something
i am aren't i
god damn it
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] it was all the way
on the right it was the second to last
page
yeah this one
no
wait
dude
okay there's no sham
it might be that i need to that he needs
to do
the thing where i take he takes the
turtle
it might be
because i feel like i've been doing this
for a while it's got to be a thing where
he needs to get in here
and i give him yeah i think so i have
the turtle okay
so mask and
turtle i have the mask and the turtle
i'm a little man
[Music]
i bet
i have something for you take it take it
take it oh come on
oh scare scratching glass okay it worked
okay this is uh okay retreating your
bedroom okay if you see me uh turn off
all the lights okay got it
whoop don't like that okay turn off all
the
lights oh god
and then what
oh god
wait oh [ __ ]
oh god what do i do i don't know
[Music]
oh god
i don't know what that is
did i have an incantation
yes i did god damn it
starting to have trouble
are these horrors becoming too
challenging for you to withstand no i
did fine
okay oh this is the uh darkness the
darkness thing the darkness
um yeah okay that symbol is already
there okay
there
[Music]
but i
i've
[Music]
it um
frick what was it if i if i'm turning
invisible i'm being spirited away that's
what it was
okay uh
well lit as possible okay well lit as
possible
okay
and then do not move
and i'm not gonna move i think that's it
i'm pretty sure that's it i don't need
to chant anything i just don't move
[Music]
goodbye
i don't know how pretending to be alive
is not moving at all but i i appreciate
it
[Applause]
are we good
okay we're good okay you've survived all
that yep just one human just me
in such a short time
becoming
becoming what i can't believe it
you're no average human thank you for
noticing you still can't escape me
she must be running out of tricks by now
the
[Music]
hold fast and prepare yourself doll okay
i've lasted this long i'm not stopping
now i'm not afraid
and then you lack imagination
oh trust me
there's nothing left of the imagination
here
okay turning invisible that's that's
doable that's easy
same old same old
all right easy peasy
i don't believe that it would do
multiple at the same time would it your
voice won't be hard okay it's a silence
one okay turn off the lights because i
need oh wait no i already know what that
is it's it's me cutting this off
okay it's the anguish outside got it
okay that's the
the
okay check the
it's not
that uh
choir of agony okay this it's this
right
yep that's it
you got it
it's the writing on the wall but don't
trust it
oh [ __ ] let me go in the mirror first
and check that i've written anything
okay i'm good
wash it away easy peasy
wash it off
easy peasy
you think i'll let you become a legend
what do you mean by that okay that's the
bad
that's the horror outside the window
oh [ __ ] what is that
oh god okay okay here we go
okay
so far so good
hello
up horse flash
easy enough
okay stand in front of the mirror chant
until holes are filled
don't lose your concentration now
[Music]
okay shadows tormenting shadows okay the
shadows
um this one
scratching glass that's the horrible
reflection i need to check it first
and then turn off all the lights okay
that's okay the lights are already off
yep that's bad
[Music]
how
hey i got stamina for days in fact the
longer this has been going on you've
seemed more and more resolved yeah it's
not possible there's no emotion stronger
than fear and no fear more powerful than
fear of the unknown but what about love
of the unknown
that's not true humans don't fear the
unknown never have if you think we do
you haven't been paying attention
even sailors the most superstitious
humans to ever walk the earth that just
set sail up to the edge of the world
they were sure was flattened inhabited
by sea monsters
we've been inventors explorers
astronauts hell we take holidays to
places we've never been for fun you're
not even stuttering anymore why aren't
you cowering before me
why would i cower before you
because you were wrong auntie
a big neon lady
there's one emotion stronger than fear
there's one feeling that every living
thing knows and it's way stronger than
fear it it can't be
it's
love
hey you said it not me
no fool it's
[Laughter]
what
you think the male praying mantis knows
fear while he's getting some hell no
ridiculous you're saying pure lust is
keeping you from being scared of me i
think i've made that quite clear from
the beginning
ever heard of the suspension bridge
effect they say when two people face
danger together they fall in love not
when one of them is the danger what's
the different you
don't you understand the cruel
indifference of the infinite cosmos
no your world your reality everything
you know and love it's all meaningless
and could vanish in an instant hey
whatever even as we speak your son spins
around the precipice of terminal
oblivion
okay
idiot the only thing that the sun spins
around is my dick
[Laughter]
and that's not all there's more you
don't realize
you really think i'm meaningless because
i'm human right you think i'm the lowest
of the low and insignificant speck not
worthy of any attention
and yet here i am in your dream
oh
i've got that right don't i auntie big
big lady nian if i'm here with you it's
because you're dreaming about me
it means i'm in your head just as much
as you are in mine i think the truth is
that you're terrified of me
you're terrified of the speed at which
i'm meeting the unknown and planting a
big wet one on it
i'm terrifying enough to have invaded
your dream after all right
you've come face to face with the
greatest threat to your power and
nothing you can throw at him seems to
stop him
and after all this after meeting lynetta
serving as steer's whims and being
subjected to the worst you have to offer
i gotta say it was all pretty fun
now tell me does this sound like it's my
nightmare or
is this yours
it's my win big lady neon
it can't be
you you think you can turn the tables on
me
hey
your words are not mine
i already have you're the second most
powerful god and you fear me
it's only a matter of time before i date
every single god you know i'm gonna leap
into the greatest unknown cosmos and
smooch that too
starting with you
pucker up big lady neon you've earned it
[Music]
he escaped from me well
i didn't escape from you
i'm still coming after you a human too
lustful to fear anything
could such a thing even exist
what horror
as soon as any of us dreams again
he undoubtedly will return to haunt our
hearts once more i'll haunt more than
that oh i'm never getting a good night's
sleep with him on the loose
[Music]
[Music]
that was wonderful
that was wonderful
i loved that
i love that
that was amazing that was incredible
oh
that's pretty cool i like that a lot
i didn't get to see me smooching big
lady nyan but
hey
such is the way of things i'll let this
play through to see if there's something
at the end of it but well done really
creative game i love it
i love it
i love it
[Music]
well i think that's all for this episode
this has been a wonderful day
however
however big however
there is clearly
there's clearly
because i i hundred percent of this but
i didn't hundred percent this i only got
four of six and yeah yeah there we go
there's a smooch in the works here and i
believe that it has to do with getting
these two endings
first and then going in the next one
that's what i'll do in the next episode
but i highly recommend that you do this
game for yourself because there's a lot
of really cool stuff here it's just this
is great i love it so thank you
everybody so much for watching links are
in the description check out my new
podcast with tyler called go my favorite
sports team and distractible and
anything else i have in the description
down there
go check it out lots of funny stuff
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
i have done research and apparently
there is no other secret ending if you
get everything
[Music]
boo
[Music]
boo
this is the final episode thank you so
much for watching
support this game it's very good okay
bye
[Music]